[Music]
what's the first time I heard one of
your song no how would I know that
because you were there we were shower
all that ever and I think it was your
first big hit was eat it that could very
well be yeah the the the beat it parity
and at one yes yes yeah that one for the
thing we're saying that one do you know
and that changed your life because you
had been doing song parodies before that
but when you came out with the eat it
song that bumped you up like 10 level
that was big I mean before EDA came out
I was basically this faceless jerk from
LA that made silly songs and after after
Eden I was a very well known jerk from
Elliott I made really bright people like
I know the name of that guy irritating
me I'd be like that back when uh MTV was
playing music videos I know that's
probably before a lot most of you were
born
yeah but the day that eat it went in the
heavy rotation I became a celebrity is
like a literal overnight Fame thing like
I would I'd be waiting a line at a
fast-food restaurant all of a sudden
people you're gonna like it guy yeah
crazy and then they would start and then
you had to dance yeah I do that too on
command they do that for people now not
Michael Jackson gave you his blessing
right yeah legal permission there's the
document somewhere with Michael
Jackson's signature next to mine saying
we are the co-writers of eat it so it's
a legal thing did you did you get to
meet him I did a couple times two or
three times and it's it's very I've ever
met Michael I never met Michael very you
know you he's super nice very
soft-spoken but it's not like you're
meeting a human I mean and I don't mean
this in a bad way
it's it's it's sort of like he's so
bigger than like you're so iconic right
it's almost like you're meeting an alien
or you're really like meeting like a
statue from from Madame Tussauds it's
like you can't possibly be real yeah
yeah well he had he certainly looked
unusual and then in pretty did he ever
invite you over to Neverland did you get
on he uh he did I think it was at a
point where it probably wouldn't been
cool to go
but uh buddy I should leave that what
about Paul McCartney as you've tried to
parody Paul McCartney's music and you
had you ran into a bit of a snag with
him is that right well you know if
everybody goes always says like who's
turned you down or I was looking for the
negative stuff and Paul McCartney I
could say I love him he's you know he's
a great guy great a great sense of humor
there was one time this was 20 years ago
I wanted to do a parody of Live and Let
Die right
and my parody brilliant idea chicken pot
pie chicken I thank you and I'm gonna
say yeah just it's not you it's God
speaks through you it's true it's true
and and Paul didn't want me to do it
because he's a strict vegetarian and he
didn't he didn't want a parody that
condoned the consumption of animal flesh
that was the whole thing he said no you
can do anything else if you want you can
do like tofu potpie
and I said well no that the chorus of my
pair doobie topitos making noise so it
worked I love that you walked away on
these artistic trans people you know
it's chicken pot pie
you